[Musique]
on se souvenait de jackie chan comme ça
mais on ne savait pas que la star du
mawashi était en fait un gros coup c'est
sa fille et amg qui nous l'a révélé hier
sur youtube classe visiblement c'est un
phénomène général
dans la famille des deux jeunes filles
ça vous choque vous extrêmement vite
je suis très sceptique benji alors à
douala je pense qu'effectivement en
revanche je pense que c'est un sale type
aujourd'hui jackie chan mais pas pour
les raisons évoquées du tout par par sa
fille
je pense pas qu'elle se soit du tout
pour cause d'homophobie puisqu'il s'en
est jamais cryptée ça vous choque pas ça
de quoi ce qu'elle a fait bah c'est
tellement dans l'air du temps c'est
tellement heureux jackie chan et la fed
ils les renier bien sûr que ça se soit
bien ça mais c'est pas pour les raisons
qu elle l avait calé un câlin votre nom
a donc ce serait pour quelles raisons
qui arrive on voit ce que l'on fait
c'est une relation d'amour haine et je
voudrais dire solennellement s'il est
chan nous écoutent pense qu'à hong kong
porte j'en suis
il faut que la famille puisse se
retrouver parce que c'est vrai qu' elle
ne le considère pas vraiment comme son
père a occupé d'elle lui la remise ou ne
l'a jamais considéré comme sa fille et
du coup il ya de graves accusations
c'est une famille qui a besoin de se
ressouder c'est vraiment un appel c'est
plus une vengeance de sa fille qu'autre
chose at c'est peut-être ça on est en
train sadima je pense que sa filiale a
tourné cette vidéo juste pour pour
l'argent parce que comme l'a déclaré en
2015 que c'est que c'est parce qu'il n'a
jamais fait partie de sa vie
il fera jamais de partir parce que ça
fait quoi qu'il arrive donc pour moi
c'est juste pour l'argent pascual vit
très mal donc elles à l'arrêt donc servi
mal c'est que son père l'aide pas
beaucoup
faire face à la grogne est oui depuis
des semaines on parle d'héritage
évidemment la logique est là s'il
s'avère que ces propos sont exacts ça
s'avère évidemment choquant mais les
tensions dans la famille tchane son
existe depuis des années elle n'a jamais
vraiment connu son père biologique la
raison gilson jamais carrément vus donc
je pense que c'est une sorte de
communication elle veut récupérer
peut-être naturellement son argent mais
on était le point intéressant c'est que
ça ça met le doigt sur un vrai problème
qui qui se passe dans le monde entier il
ya plein de jeunes homosexuels qui se
font [ __ ] à la porte de chez heures ne
serait ce juste parce qu'ils sont
homosexuels et au moins salaces à
l'intérêt de parler de ce sujet là et
d'ailleurs si vous avez bonne part les
llanos n'ai pas contacté leur refusant
d'afficher le nom est évidemment c'est
très important ce n'est pas donner moi
mon fils d'une famille sans savoir tous
les tenants et les aboutissants
travailler pour que l'école alors on a
permis six mois ça vous choque
cette affaire est de vous choquer pas
choquant c'est partager mais je
partageais ccc partager mais c'est que
les gens ont la même fondation vouée que
vie c'est plus un coup de com qu'autre
chose non mme isabelle a raison c'est
compliqué les règlements de compte par
médias interposés on n'est pas juge des
affaires familiales on n'a pas tous les
tenants et les aboutissants à l'arche
effectivement les dires et leurs proches
sont abjects et abominable mais l'art
est d'accord